[Rires]
[Musique]
l'aube n'aurait pas dû avoir ce matin-là
la même banalité que les autres
matins il est vrai que le grand
événement qui devait se produire sur le
territoire des 13 académies de la zone A
échappa aux populations
laborieuses il concnait pourtant près du
quart des habitants la première vague
des 12 millions de Français d'âge
scolaire allait prendre le chemin de
l'école un chemin oublié depuis de longs
mois pas de problème de logement
cependant cette année malgré 370000
élèves de plus le retard en bâtiment a
été rattrapé
reste le cas des enfants astreints pour
la première fois à la prolongation de la
scolarité de 14 à 16 ans le problème est
nouveau et il faudra occuper ces 130000
élèves
prolongés et puis il y a les
materneles bagager un pass bonsoir on a
tout dit sur le premier jour de classe
le premier contact avec l'école l'entrée
dans la condition écolière c'est la
première vraie mutation dans la vie d'un
enfant le deuxè
sevrage et c'est pourquoi la scène se
joue parfois comme un petit drame en
trois actes au lev de rideau de
8h30
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le nombre d'enfants de 3 à 5 ans ne
cesse d'augmenter cette année il va
falloir faire front à la vague de 2
millions de petits écoliers et trouver
le moyen de les faire
[Musique]
sourire la
mais les hommes de l'autre côté les
homes F oui petit F elle va à l'école
maternelle
il y a beaucoup de mèr sans doute ce
jour-là qui se sont sentis tout à coup
orphelines
d'enfant quel âge a-elle elle a 4 ans
mais est dernière
[Musique]
déj
le savoir est de beaucoup la portion la
plus considérable du bonheur
[Musique]
socle
alleluja
allelu alluia
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
allelu
[Musique]
alleluia alleluia alleluia
alleluja
Allel